[Music]
and is our great pleasure to have with
us grandmas Maurice Ashley joining us
here in the studio thanks so much thank
you for being here surprise surprise wow
you know there's a big event here I got
to show up just to hang out with you you
all and have a bit of fun wow welcome
Maurice what's I mean it's it's
wonderful having you here at the
singfield cup what you been up to you
know I've been up to quite a few things
with my books that are coming out in a
in a few months right an adult book on
wisdom of Chess that I've gained over
the years we all have learned from this
wonderful game and also a children's
book on my life which is a a book for
early readers both of those are coming
out on April 2nd and they're ready for
pre-order on Amazon so if you want to
check that out April
2 there something Weir funny about that
one yeah somehow that both Publishers
decided to do it on the exact same day
and of course the chessable courses I'm
trying to catch up with you yes I'm at
my fourth course now I just finished how
to reassess your chest but J Silman as
you know he recently passed on so I had
that opportunity to voice that classic
so happy about that so you know just
trying to stay busy all right and of
course watching you all do a fabulous
job on the show and uh obviously we're
at the sinkfield Cup Final Tournament of
the grand chest T have you been
following I have I have I've been
watching all of you do a masterful job
Peter handling the big
board with with Incredible finess the
biggest and sight as always so yes it's
absolutely B an interesting blow up in
the
couple of rounds all heck broke loose
and people started bashing each other
which was cool to see of course today's
draws don't seem so exciting little
distasteful on two of the games thus far
they happen under underneath an hour and
less than an hour game was games were
okay well everything there's so much at
stake right there's the candidate spots
I mean have you been following the race
there you know with the feed day circuit
and the feed day ratings I mean what are
your thoughts on that I think it's crazy
I mean it's wild the the rating issue is
of course always with controversy who's
not played enough and and the like um
but it's still fun to I mean it looks
like chess is just born to have
controversy it's what we do right
there's always something going on and
and so it's fun to see it's crazy to
think that four Americans might get into
the candidates that's absolutely insane
I mean the thought came out of nowhere
why is this guy he never loses to the
sinkfield what's up that I know is an
elite tournament all the best players in
the world oh but I never lose I mean
what is that about that's incredible
been a beast so far absolutely wow well
here we are uh Maurice we might even be
seeing a third um Grandmaster draw this
this one is less not this one I meant uh
Leon sorry I meant not Le against they
they've been repeating I believe well
the the offer is on the table here I
really feel like switching the camera
away from Maurice is a is a crime
against humanity let's put chess pieces
on the board here for a second we've
already had this repetition once and
lener is clearly now considering whether
he should be playing Rook F2 he is now
down to 50 minutes uh against somebody
who is very very obviously uh had this
on their screen today Rook F2 is
playable as we've discussed it's maybe
even a little bit better for why but the
positions are quite sharp lineer is
tight first Fabi has already drawn his
game so King H1 wouldn't be a horrible
practical decision for us as you know
viewers of the tournament we would very
much like Rook F2 here right but you you
wouldn't really you know blame him very
much if he if he decides to go King H1
and this one also disappears off our
screens of course we would blame him we
want to see blood what you talking about
what about the million dooll open no
draws you know you got to play for the
win yeah these they're so good
everyone's so good actually this morning
I just came in yesterday and
miraculously had a chance to have
breakfast with Maxim this morning okay
and we were chatting about different
things statistics being one of them we
know he's a ma mathematician and it
looks like repetition is taking place
sadly uh and and I asked I said Maxim
you know what's the deal why when are
you going to be back score a win yeah
when are you going to be back period
like it's it's you I'm not used to
seeing Maxim drop out of the top 10 the
way he has like a rock as you we see
this repetition taking place his typical
French mace Maurice I I must play
better yeah that'll
help that's one of the things you got to
do yeah just do it already and you know
we we've not seen him show his best but
of course he's one of the best prepared
players and as Peter said we can't blame
him if lanir says not this one this guy
this guy looks like he knows what he's
doing right well we do see on the camera
Maxim thinking hard he looks like he
might be considering the Alternatives
but I'm not an expert on body language
and uh Maurice when it comes to the
stats you you mentioned you know that
you were discussing stats I mean we've
come up with some stats our resident uh
stais Ben andwood came up with some very
interesting stats about like there being
48 point was it close to 50% decisive
gam was the
originator all those things
talkinging to the choir I know but were
you surprised by how things like turned
out you know statistics has been
something as Yas knows he and I have
talked about it quite a bit
unfortunately sadly Yasser is a Dallas
Cowboy fan so
peace you know blessings to the Dallas
Cowboys for all the joy that they bring
to their fans yeah I'm a New York Giants
fan as he know so the opportunity to
needle he's not going to lose that given
how badly we're doing it they're doing a
little bit better understandings but
nevertheless we know that watching
sports stats are a huge part of it
analytics as transformed basketball
without any question about it it used to
be pound you know in the in the paint
now players are shooting threes like
it's going out of style and the
transformation is from the numbers and
chess I mean it's really an analytical
game that's what we do and there are
numbers hiding in plain sight that we
have not explored fully enough I think
given all the data we have so it's cool
to be able to work with somebody like
young Ben Underwood who for me it's like
I'm a kid in a candy store talking to
him and asking him about the various
stats the move counts the the averages
and the like and there's some surprising
things that have come out of it for
example when when I remember you were
asked about early rounds or later rounds
deis the most decisive penultimate
penultimate was yeah the fight's taking
place at the end is the penultimate what
we're seeing right now the penultimate
this is what's happened this is what the
stats say this is what happens in the
later rounds players are more inclined
to draws and your intuition is one thing
but Peter you you mentioned I remember
you you being stunned by a a couple of
stats as well but let me show you you
see some in this data
there's uh about which rounds are the
most decisive oh here we go seeing feel
upset sorry this is a new one let's go
okay the most significant upsets
by black over white oh
Magnus remember that not sure it counts
officially anymore largest white over
black wait a second Carlson versus K 76
rating points is the largest upset with
the black pieces outside of the Newan
game right and the lowest spea rating to
win a game was darush versus Jeffrey I'm
that's that I think this interesting
stat between car and carolana I think
that's the case because usually there's
not a significant rating difference
between the players because very few I
mean it's usually the top players in the
tournament that are invited so the Gap
is smaller so that 76 which would seem
somewhat surprising in an open
tournament for example would be stunning
in an open tournament is not so
surprising here for me when we were
talking about stats and as we were
coming into the very very first
broadcast we have the zoom call with you
Maurice and you were saying that you and
Ben had done this you know detailed look
at some of the stats for me one of the
things that you pulled out which was a
real gem was one lanir Dominguez nobody
beat lenir right didn't see that coming
at all that's like yeah so we should be
doing more analytics with the Chess
World it's just it it lends itself
perfectly it's in its infancy now as you
start making these comparisons the
players M El could benefit one of the
things that I found stunning I believe
it was a Wesley stat that said he's the
worst performer in the second half of
the tournament on the tour MH right
wouldn't guess that I don't want to get
pointed out as the worst performer put
the finger on that guy wait minute why
you show but it's kind of interesting
you if you're doing well at the
beginning but you're not performing
later what are the reasons for that or
even things like long games Peter fidler
uh me pet Peter you pointed out that the
stat when Yan was the one who performed
who won his games in the longest time
now to me when you think Yan punish you
that's fire and brimstone and throwing
you know all kinds of craziness on the
board tactics he must be winning games
quickly how was y the one 65 move
average 65 moves Yan the P the you you
would have had me guess 10 players and
he would have been number 10 maybe ala
would have been number 10 but not not
Yan those are was actually at the top so
with Al you would have been completely
correct but Yan yeah it's a very
counterintuitive stud there and as I
mentioned yeah I I think people
underestimate if we talk about Yan just
how good of a technical player he is and
how much he enjoys winning slightly
better positions just by being more
precise over a long stretch but but this
but this whole stat that is like a well
uh a a rich vein to dig and to get these
uh you know and think about that as a
player think about as a player not just
as commentators and fans think about as
AER you say oh it's Neo he's a fighter
you know fire Brimstone keep the game
calm let's let's go into an end game and
then the stat says dude wins all the end
games whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a second
that may not be what we want to do
that's not the key to beating him right
so that's where I think strategically
you can start integrating statistical
analysis with with performance and
that's what we care about I don't care
what you understand in chess I don't
care what you know how do you perform
that's what we really want to know and
and how do we perform individually as
players have we done a statistical
analysis on your own games what what do
they show they might show something
surprising yeah I would love to see that
right you know just to have uh some data
on whether I do well on closed positions
open positions the bishop the Knight you
know because we have certain assumptions
about our play but the stats will prove
otherwise I was stunned looking at my
games I used to think I was such a
tactician I always wanted to attack and
when I reviewed my games
long long retired and looking at my
games I was like this guy is boring who
is this guy he's trading off in the game
in the game I was looking at all the
crazy variations did I play the solid
move what so a lot to be seen from real
analysis I I remember my own case it was
pretty uh funny I'm going to play a
match here in St Louis against anat kpof
Holy Smokes you're could to play one of
the world's greatest players ever
Anatoli carbuff you're going to take it
seriously so I did this uh openings uh
search what am I going to play against
anator I know he's going to play D4 I
got a problem I'm GNA play D4 I want to
surprise him I'm going to play the Dutch
scores
72% tear that one up okay I'm going to
surprise him I'm going to play
this and it turned out the SLO defense
and I chose the SLO defense because uh
sorry Jo you want to say by the way you
know the players have repeat it three
times third Grandmaster draw out of
three games and statistics say round
round eight one of the dud rounds but
that was funny but let's talk about that
for just a moment because it was round
one was the most exciting and seven out
of the nine winners of round one won the
SFO cup all draws second round
statistically speaking was the most
decisive all draws again
allit three in a row uh we were at z00 Z
and now we're at 25% coming into today
yeah not not
anymore 25% although I should if there's
a decisive result in the last one we're
still at 25% after that but it it it
seems so we started underwhelming uh
underwhelming with all of these draws
but 25% is probably an average for the
singfield cup is that right that's it
depends on the round yeah overall the
overall tournament yes the challenge
with an event like this and for I think
it's a question even for the grand chest
tour maybe an existential question is
when you have all these strong players
playing classical chess
exactly pretty good and in the age of uh
engines that show openings to raise your
thin margins you're not getting an edge
black is perfectly fine everywhere you
look is this the right design even is a
question we have to ask because yes you
get the best best chess so to speak you
get the most accurate chess but are you
getting the most entertaining show
necessarily and and there's some
tournaments that combine top players
with low rated players I I'd love to
hear Peter chime in on this what do you
think I mean you look at a tournament
coming up like Tata steel and it's
always belligerent I mean there's blood
on the board because the top players are
going okay wait a minute there's a point
there's a point there's a point and and
and it just creates an Ambiance for
ferocity uh and aggression is this NE
necessarily the ideal way to go for us
we just had the contrast we had the St
Louis rapid and Blitz prior to the
singfield cup which had a huge number of
decisive and belligerency Maurice we're
going to be going to a break but thank
you so much for uh coming on the show I
mean it's nice to have you around it's
really really really great to see you
join us his books send out your likes
absolutely and uh well we are going to
take very short break but don't go
anywhere cuz we are going to be back
with more of the chess action between
Richard report and leevon aronian so
don't go
anywhere